all right
ian ian where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
ohio and tell me about your family you
had both your parents
growing up uh mom and step dad
and how would you describe your
childhood it was good
no views nothing like that nothing
it was happy it's great
what kind of kid were you in high school
uh
started off as an athlete then kind of
slacked off
then went to vocational and got trades
what kind of jobs have you had all kinds
mainly construction
you've been married you have kids
[Music]
at one point you got convicted of uh the
sex defense
yep tell me about that attempted loom
lascivious battery
i got caught in a sting operation
and pretty much couldn't afford a lawyer
so i got sent to prison for three years
and now you're branded a sex offender
for the rest of your life yep
you have to register what every year uh
six months maybe six months
and is that does that affect your
job opportunities or oh yeah
how does it affect your life well i'm
stuck living here
yeah i can only go so many places
i gotta stay in the county i have a
curfew
and this is going to go on for three
years so it was just one offense that
you were convicted of yep how old was
the
was the girl they said between 14 and
16.
tell me about what happened i go online
for
a hookup site and i went to a bunch of
them
one responded back talked to her and
then finally she said she was 14
and i said you're just a kid so why are
you on here
but then the next night i went on all
the same sites
got responded again it was the same one
then i ended up going to meet her
stopped at the gas station got all these
weird texts
saying she's a virgin what are you gonna
teach me blah blah i was like yeah it's
probably a bad idea
but a cop pulled up the gas station and
he recognized me and
said i'd look like i'm not from around
there
so i didn't go to the sting house but i
was close enough
so they convicted me with uh travel to
me minor
so you never actually touched anyone no
you just
looked like you were you attempted to or
you you tried to meet one
what is that lesson what lesson have you
learned from this uh don't do
a bunch of drugs were you doing drugs
yeah
yeah that would kind of set the it
changes your uh
ability to your perspective she's right
and wrong
and how has this affected your your
family
your relationship with your family my
relationship's fine
yeah they know who i am
but i can't see them because i can't
leave the county
they can't come down here to covet
i couldn't see him for three years
because i was in prison
so kind of lost some connection but
still talk to him all the time
yeah and your friends yeah
mainly family brothers people i work
with
guys around here
what kind of emotions do you do you deal
with over this i mean is anger is there
depression is there
anxiety i was gonna name those three
anxiety being the biggest yeah
what is the anxiety over what are you
worried about
uh this box i have on my ankle um
like last night i have to carry this
thing around
and it went off last night telling me to
go home when i was at home
and then it never cleared so they called
me
where you at i'm at home my probation
officer called me this morning
she said what are you doing like i
promised you i was at home
she said well done so you were it's like
i don't know what to tell you i was at
home
because this was after curfew what is
your curfew time
10 o'clock you gotta be home by ten yeah
unless i'm at work
and what are you working as what are you
doing for work now i'm cooking
it's about the only jobs we can get
can't work on people's houses because
there might be kids around i'm not
supposed to be around minors
period while i'm on probation yeah and
you're in this mobile home park where
it's nothing but sex offenders
correct so you guys have to you know
you're in a situation where you're
staying away from kids
because we are very limited to where we
can live right
and when you give your id for something
job application something like that
does it come up yeah but i bring it up
first thing because there's no hiding it
no not at all
and i don't want to hide it i mean i
made a stupid mistake
but now i'm paying for it so i have to
acknowledge it do you still have an
attraction to young young girls or is it
just the drugs kind of
changed your i was just looking for
someone
that night i don't have an attraction to
young girls or boys
what's the most painful part of all this
for you
not seeing my family in ohio
and of course the money
i got 6 500 bracelet
so and how do you feel all this is
this experience has changed you sobered
me up
has it made me realize uh
life goes by pretty quick
what advice would you give to somebody
else who's living a reckless life like
you were
uh take a step back look at yourself
see if you're doing good or bad
just try to get sober for a minute then
you can actually see yourself
and don't do something stupid
my stupid mistake ruined my life
other people's stupid mistakes could
take someone's life so
at least i only hurt myself
all right ian well thank you so much for
talking with me and good luck with uh
your the rest of your life from here
you're on the right path now which is
great
yeah just trying worst part is is
laura told me get me off of everything
for ten thousand dollars
but i didn't have that
so i went with public representer it's
only do an open plea
he said i'll probably just get probation
and the judge said
i'll just learn three years probation
after three years doc
and by the way you're going to register
the rest of your life let go
great thanks lawyer looked at me and
said
sorry bud so if you get stuck in a
situation
do your best to get the money to get a
lawyer
because sex offenders any sex offense
whether it be victimless or whatever
judges don't care if they don't like it
unless you have a good lawyer
they can find all the rules and this
ruins your life for
for how long the rest of it the rest of
me
i register the rest of my life is that
right
that determines where i live where i
work
okay thank you so much all right thank
you
you